salut c'est monsieur dray aujourd'hui je
vous emmène avec moi sur vacances à
encre et regardez moi ça est-ce qu'on
est fan on est plutôt bien
donc aujourd'hui je vais vous parler du
drone le hanafi de parrot
on l'a testé il ya pas très longtemps je
sais pas si vous vous en souvenez on
était au polo club de chantilly passe à
120 de paris j'ai attendu quelques temps
le ton bien de prendre en main de le
tester de quoi faire pas mal de choses
avec
et là je vous emmène avec moi
aujourd'hui en vacances en crète dans un
endroit quand même relativement
paradisiaque pour tester ce drôle alors
ça fait pas mal de plans aériens
justement ça te dit avoir un spot qui
soit super top et là pour le coup on est
vraiment servi vous allez voir la
machine de parrot est vraiment bien il a
des points qui sont vraiment superbes en
terme d'expérience pour ce faire plaisir
il est génial il ya quelques points de
regret il ya deux trois trucs que je
regrette peut-être améliorer pour une
prochaine fois en attendant c'est quand
même un super neurones tout est ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va prendre de
l'altitude et on va aller voir s'il est
cool
m
[Musique]
pour pouvoir trouver le meilleur spot
pour poser la caméra et croyez moi
conscient keyyo c'est pas évident la
boîte est plutôt bien fait c'est
vachement compact pas dans un sac à dos
sans aucun problème là j'ai un petit sac
à dos herschel ça fonctionne super bien
donc là vous avez écrit paroles sur le
dessus plutôt bien
j'aime beaucoup parce que je trouve que
c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper compact
lorsque volou vrai tout est dedans
vous avez en plus à l'intérieur un petit
adaptateur de carte micro sd pour mettre
dans votre ordi et surtout c'est le
format compact il se dit très très
facilement ça c'est plutôt cool
voilà là vous avez le bouton pour
l'allumer et il est prêt à partir vous
avez un petit cache sur la caméra qui ne
fait pas à perdre pas perdre oubliez
navets et surtout pas perdre
petit cache là la batterie elle s'enlève
extrêmement facilement vous appuyé par
des batteries de rechange aussi vous
pouvez acheter votre carte micro sd
trouve là donc ça c'est plutôt cool
plutôt pratique pour l'allumer hop le
petit bouton la manette aussi est plutôt
cool assez compact derrière vous avez
des petits joystick pour piloter l'angle
de la caméra il pour piloter zoom vous
pouvez prendre des photos
mais enfin c'est vraiment pratique le
bouton retourner à la maison qui est las
de ce que de ce point de vue en tout cas
sergo nomique est relativement simple
pour connecter votre smartphone vous
avez qu à le prendre vous le posez tac
tac tac comme ça vous allumez
directement forêt dans l'appli tri
flight 6 de parrot que vous trouvez bien
sûr gratuitement sur l'appstore et sur
le ps store est également la grenette
allumé par contre
par contre voilà là j'ai un problème
c'est que c'est pas reconnu ils se
reconnaissent pas this vu dans mes
réglages bluetooth je crois qu'il le
trouve pas c'est un peu le problème que
j'ai là dessus ça c'est un truc qui
m'emmerde un peu depuis quelques jours
je pense que tu n'en parles résoudre
pour la solution mais a pour l'instant
ça marche
je vais essayer par contre quand on a
fait les tests qui marche extrêmement
bien donc je pense que c'est moi qui
reliera d'avoir un truc avec mon iphone
c'est pourquoi c'est très bizarre
du coup je branche mon iphone je branche
ce truc là là c'est pas terrible mais
comme ça ça se reconnaît qu'il faille
souhaite communiquer la volaille
autorise la communication souffler et là
ça marche bien allez savoir pourquoi
[Musique]
alors vous avez deux modes pour le faire
décoller lorsque vos drone est allumée
il le reconnut à la main et il sait que
vous allez le faire décoller directement
comme ça sinon vous poser au sol il le
reconnaît vous avez un bouton pour faire
décoller des cols directement par qu'on
voulait faire décoller la main c'est
marrant il comprend juste le jeter en
l'air et d'écoles ça c'est cool
ça c'est ce qui s'appelle un décollage
raté alors j'ai tordu un peu une hélice
mais de rechange ça voudrait le faire on
va le tester comme ça aurait semé dans
un endroit peu plus safe pour le faire
décoller cela évitera de tout casser
ça serait beaucoup
alors
saleh
[Musique]
la deuxième possibilité c'est le faire
décoller directement avec la
télécommande sur la télécommande vous
appuyez sur les cov
[Musique]
pour les deux modes de décollage sont
quand même relativement simple le drone
vol plutôt bien donc ça c'est un bon
point et pour la sphère intérieur vous
appuyez sur l'inde et la taille tout
seul
[Musique]
et
mais
à
[Musique]
point positif points négatifs points
positifs déjà c'est le format compact et
puis c'est le grand retour de parrot sur
ce type au logis de produits parrot un
huissier les drones personnel il ya
quelques années puis sont écoulés par
des gi's a aidé plusieurs pour eux là il
y avait vraiment avec un produit qui a
su faire bien gagner malgré tout il ya
des points négatifs
le premier point qui pouvait lui
reprocher c'est qu'il va pas se
connecter en radio il va se connecter
uniquement wifi alors uniquement c'est
déjà bien comme symbole de résistance
est absolument aucun problème
néanmoins que ça me rassurerait plus
d'avoir un contrôleur radio plutôt le
contrôleur du fij sais pas ce que vous
en pensez
alors que là tout ça directement en bas
en commentaire ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point que je vais accrocher
par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui à la concurrence notamment
chez dj hi c'est qu'il n'a pas de
reconnaissance d'obstacles c'est à dire
que votre rôle lorsqu'il va revenir tout
seul par exemple
retour à la maison si lille a signé au
milieu il trouve un arbre ou quoi que ce
soit il va pas pouvoir les reconnaître
écouter directement dessus et ça c'est
quand même vraiment vraiment vraiment
dommage parce qu'on est quand même sur
un produit qui coûte à peu près 700
euros donc si basse tout un art
alors qu'harry concurrence sur des
produits de didier vous n'êtes pas en
cause
c'est quand même con c'est quand même
franchement ça pour moi c'est les deux
points négatifs de ce produit alors
point positif est qu'ils étaient
vraiment là super grande force de ce
produit c'est sa caméra sa caméra parce
que vous pouvez la noter dans tous les
sens et ça c'est génial c'est à dire que
elle va aller filmer droit de coter vont
être forcément sur le bas mais également
sur le haut ce qui fait que si vous
passez par exemple sous un pont devra
avoir des effets qui sont complètement
cool vous allez pouvoir filmer le ciel
redescendre filmé en bas et faire des
travellings que vous pouvez pas faire
avec les drones de la concurrence et ça
pour le coup c'est vraiment génial et
c'est vraiment le point d'innovations et
le point fort de ce produit ça vous
permet de capter d'autres choses ne
pouvaient pas qui attaque de trop pour
ça c'est vraiment cool
félicitations par un autre point qui
écoule ses design il a un look un peu de
la libellule
ça change un peu c'est pas mal c'est
vraiment bien fait chez moi je trouve
que sinon après en terme d'expérience de
pilotage c'est bien vous avez deux modes
soit le mode sport là il va carburer il
a filé tout droit
soit vous le mettez en mode film là il
va les plus cool je vais vous aurez pas
de mouvements saccadés
lorsque vous allez film est alors seul
mode sport vous avancez vous relâchez il
part c'est vachement saccadé bon par
contre en terme de pilotage nous fait
vraiment plaisir mais s'il voulait
capter de belles images
c'est toujours un petit peu dommage
après le pilotage se fait super bien
c'est assez intuitif pour ma part je me
perds un peu dans les commandes parce
que vous avez d'origine là
l'altitude ont fait descendre avancer
reculer
et là vous faites aller en latéral d'un
côté de l'autre et pour faire tourner
c'est celui-là
j'aurais plus ici moi avancer et reculer
droit de gaucher ici les latéraux avec
le gaz donc ça peut se paramétrer
d'origine c'est comme ça c'est pas très
grave
après ce qui est bien c'est
qu'effectivement vous et pas mal de
possibilités jeu
pour enregistrer directement des vidéos
à savoir que lorsqu'ils d'école du film
déjà directement donc ça c'est aussi un
excellent point est filmé en 4k c'est
plutôt pas mal moi pour ma part je filme
en full hd
pas besoin de 4,4
sur 4,4 gauche et pour tout vous dire un
mac qui n'aime pas du tout la 4k qui
rame encore donc pour l'instant on
passera plus tard à la 4k pour l'instant
vos billets vous avez ici le zoom et là
vous pilotez votre caméra ici sur la
vente
donc en termes de commandes s'est
vraiment intuitif et c'est super bien
fichu pareil vous l'ouvrez ça serait
facilement les l'impression de
robustesse et ça c'est plutôt cool sur
cette apologie de produits prouve que la
qualité est là c'est vraiment un produit
qu'elle s'imprègne piloter vous avez
plusieurs possibilités alors appris j'ai
pas tout détailler force que si vous
voulez plus de détails vous pouvez aller
voir directement sur le site de parrot
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis un lien menant
description si ce produit vous intéresse
vous avez différents types de mode pour
le piloter ya pas mal de questions
pour moi c'est vivre parce que ce que je
voulais partager c'est vraiment mon
expérience dans qu une vue générale
les novices je suis pas un expert en
pilotage de drone je peux pas vous dire
ce que pourrait faire un expert experts
pour aller beaucoup plus loin sur ce
type au logis de produits par contre je
trouve que pour avoir un premier drone
qui est bien qu'il tient bien celui ci
se trouve vraiment intéressant je peux
c'est vraiment une belle réussite
après je pense que parrot perrier encore
plus loin sur une tête une seconde
génération ou un modèle pro qui pourrait
arriver plus tard les technos claque ça
me paraît vraiment aujourd'hui important
et primordial
c'est le fait de mettre des commandes
radio et pas des comores
j'ai la flotte qui m'arrive de souk all
vip être les vagues arrivaient derrière
je crois qu'il est temps qu'une un peu
vous avez survécu à la vague voilà pour
ce retour d'expérience de ce drone de
hanafi je trouve que je vous laisse
quand même regarder un petit peu le sol
vous allez voir c'est un peu casse
gueule seul aventure ici mais le spot
est juste magnifique
regardez moi ça je sais pas si vous
connaissez la crête si vous avez déjà eu
l'occasion de venir franchement vous
pouvez venir les yeux fermés c'est super
mais ainsi un peu il ya un peu de vent
mais malgré tout c'est pareil il peut
supporter du vent allant jusqu'à 55 km
heure c'est je dis pas de bêtises donc
là dessus aussi vous êtes franchement
tranquille il revient bien et ce pilote
bien alors après il ya un autre point
aussi que je peux reprocher c'est que
lorsque vous regardez sur votre
contrôleur le niveau de wi fi des fois
alors qu'il n'est pas très loin et vous
marquez niveau de wifi faible néanmoins
en fait pas la connexion satan est
rassurant mais bon voilà je vous dis que
c'est jamais sperme en drones qui paraît
collection et à viendra tout seul mais
comme il n'ya pas les texans d'obstacles
ça peut être un peu embêtant son camp je
le fais voler au dessus de l'eau j'ai
toujours un peu flipper alors une fois
de plus ça vient de moi parce que je
suis pas un spécialiste du pilotage de
drones mais je trouve plutôt coût du
voyage ce que vous en pensez vous est-ce
que vous avez déjà des drones de la
concurrence je pense notamment à dj
qu'aujourd'hui le
numéro un de son marché du grand public
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la nef
parrot marque moto sans commentaire que
je vous invite à rester connectés parce
que de toute façon ce drone on va le
faire voler régulièrement dans
différentes occasions se permettra de
vous en reparler régulièrement tout vous
dire ce que j'en pense puis la rentrée
se profile donc il va y avoir plein de
nouveautés un nouveau forme un nouveau
venu règle pas nous autres idées à des
aventures on va partir à berlin d'ici
quelques jours
à l'ifa il ya plein de trucs super cool
donc merci à vous une fois de plus
d'être présent toujours plus nombreuse
toujours plus nombreux sur cette jolie
shy'm j'espère qu'on va aller encore
plus loin tous ensemble merci et puis je
vous laisse avec un ti un petit coup de
mer petit coup de mer un peu agitée
sympathique l'histoire de vous remettre
dans les vacances parce que vous êtes
parti si vous allez partir que ça peut
être l'occasion allait jouer un petit
coup de flottes comme ça ça fait
toujours du bien
m